horror films don't get much respect
but while horror has often been
dismissed as lowbrow its music has been
anything but listen to the score from
the 2018 horror thriller bird box
now check this up here the similarities
this experimental composition was a key
part of the Exorcist
a film that changed horror music forever
but what is that sound and how did it
come to influence the horror films of
today
naari and I are gonna compose a score
for an original scary short but first
let's take a look back at how scary
music has evolved from the silent era to
the Exorcist to today since there's been
filmed there's been horror in the silent
era most films would either have no
music or they would be accompanied by
live musicians who would play popular or
classical tunes only a handful of silent
horror films were accompanied by
original scores the music written for
the 1920 release of the cabinet of dr.
Caligari was described by one theatre
runner as eligible for citizenship and a
nightmare country the first time a
thematic musical score was written for a
feature-length American talkie was for
the 1933 monster movie King Kong written
by composer Max Steiner this score
utilized techniques that would go on to
be used in horror films for decades such
as Mickey Mouse II in which music
matches a character's action
and light motifs which are short
recurring musical ideas that typically
signify the presence of a monster or a
villain it's a technique John Williams
would later use in what's likely one of
the most memorable film scores of all
time
this tune outline motif is perfect not
only for its menacing simplicity but
also for its functionality the quicker
it gets the closer we know the sharpness
[Music]
during Hollywood's golden age horror
films and the score is written for them
often lacks subtlety the music usually
told the audience what to fear 50s was
so big giant ants and these aliens from
outer space where 60s psycho kicked it
off
it was personal it's a lot of
interpersonal drama but now herrmann's
score in that is iconic psycho shower
scene is one of the earliest examples of
a jump scare and is one of the most
famous examples of a stinger cord a
common horror music technique where
musicians sharply attack a chord to
reinforce the moment of surprise
Hitchcock originally wanted the shower
seemed to be silent but composer bernard
herrmann decided to write a piece
featuring violins playing a shrieking
upward Lassonde which is produced when a
violinist glides the fingers up or down
the strings as they play
Hitchcock later said that 33% of the
effective cycle was due to the music I
watch a lot of superhero movies sure the
Avenger score is cool but I'm not gonna
think of the Avenger score when I'm like
kicking butt but when I'm scared alone
at night I think of that hard movies for
one reason the Stinger cords so
effectively heightened terror and horror
films is that they manipulate the
deep-rooted fear centers in our brains
what makes something scary mental work
has shown is that screams that are
fear-based screams and they're known to
have a very particular kind of acoustic
signature what's called roughness and
that gives it the kind of scraggly
fluttery vibe whether they're vocal as
sounds or alarm sounds or other sounds
it's the ones that have increased
roughness feature and that's what you
interpret as a listener as fearful it
could be a guitar string could be a
piano sound be anything now let's
fast-forward to the film that changed
horror music forever The Exorcist
William Friedkin's 1973 classic was so
terrifying that it caused audience
members to faint vomit and protest its
release some people even thought the
film itself was possessed that's partly
because of its unforgettable soundtrack
which included disturbing experimental
compositions that went on to shape the
way horror scores and soundtracks sound
even to this day
that's the sound of Krishna's Penderecki
the leader of the Polish school of
avant-garde composers in the 1950s and
60s to get this haunting sound Pender s
key used tools like sound masses and
tone clusters tender Russ's score I I
don't know it sounds classic I love a
song that I don't know when it was
composed I didn't know if Penn rescue
was from the 1700s or now and I love
that it has this timeless sound to it
it's timelessly scary as well so to
create a tone cluster you can basically
take a number of pitches that are a
semitone apart for example f-sharp G
g-sharp these are all tone clusters with
sound masks the focus is more on the
effect as a whole where we have a clump
of pitches where the specificity of each
note and rhythm matters less than the
texture as a whole his use of these
compositional tools defied the classical
form and help take the exorcist to a
demonic dimension although pen duress
Keys music feels like a horror film he
didn't write it from the screen much of
his experimental work was inspired by
the real-life terrors of world war ii as
a boy in Poland in the wretzky witnessed
the violence of Nazis in his hometown of
debita Penda rescues music was also used
in another landmark horror film Stanley
Kubrick's The Shining horror music
horror phenomena I've never seen a real
horror film from start to finish ever
ever this is not your cup of tea when I
was little I used to get scared watching
documentaries about you know those
documentaries that talk about haunted
houses or whatever yeah that's the be
real dog do you think that there's a
stereotypical horror film sound
I think the shrieking violins stuff in
the higher register yeah or even any any
dissonant interval dissonance is a
common aspect of horror
music one of the most effective ways to
utilize it is through the tritone
musical interval composed of three
adjacent whole tones a major third or a
perfect fifth these are all consonant
intervals where they sit quite
comfortably in the ear let's compare
that to a tritone there's more tension
there
it's a clashing dissonant sound that has
helped it earn the name the devil's
interval in music and you can hear it in
many horror films like during the canoe
scene in Friday the 13th where composer
Harry Manfredini repeats to try tones a
half step apart
another common technique is to put
familiar or non-threatening music into a
creepy context often it's little kids
singing children's songs also quoting
religious music can help set the stage
for films that traffic in the demonic
Wendy Carlos and Rachel Elkind
use this technique in the opening of The
Shining with the recomposition of DA's
array a 13th century Gregorian chain
playing instruments in specific or
extreme ways is another powerful tool in
horror film music you'll often hear
violins play soul ponticello which means
close to the bridge combined with
tremolo to produce eerily shrill sounds
sometimes simple techniques can be just
as effective at heightening dread in
horror films such as using a bass line
to mimic the sound of a heartbeat as
John Carpenter did in the theme the
steady heartbeat gives us a clue that
something menacing is constantly lurking
nearby
and it's coming for the characters say
that if just with strings
there's something about sustaining a
high note like can you hear that mm-hmm
that just build tension the more you do
it also really low things like less yeah
and then you put a cluster
[Music]
do you want to approach the meet me
riding the bike in the hallway in front
of the twins I'll approach the door okay
now here's the score that we made for
horror film starring Toussaint Morrison
from our fellow PBS series America from
scratch
little pigs little pigs let me come in
not by the hair of my chinny-chin-chin
Wow ha ha
or officer
[Music]
monstrum is a new show from PBS Digital
Studios about monsters myth and lore the
show is written and hosted by dr. Emily
Zarqa who has a PhD in literature with a
focus on monsters basically she's a
doctor of monsters head to the link in
the description to check out the show
and find out the origins of iconic
monsters
[Music]